ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه لاخر التطورات في
داخل السوداني سنبدا باخر التطورات
الميدانيه حيث دوه اطلاق نار كثيف وتصاعدت
اعمده الدخان في محيط القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه بالخرطوم وقال الجيش
السوداني انه سيطر على مقر قياده الدعم
السريع في كردفان وذلك في وقت يشهد فيه
محيط مطار الخرطوم اطلاق نار كثيف وتصاعد
اعمده الدخان وفي مراويه فدمر رسل العربيه
نقلا عن مصادر عسكريه ببسط الجيش السوداني
سيطرته الكامله على مطار والقاعده الجويه
فيماوي واجبر قوات الدعم السريع على
مغادره القاعده بعد اشتباكات عنيفه وصحبت
معها نحو 27 من الجنود المصريين اما حصيله
القتلى والجرحى جراء المواجهات بين
الطرفين فهي اخذه بالتزايد
ون
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
هذا مشاهدينا ولا تزالوا تسمع بعض اصوات
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدرع السريع او الرد عفوا وذلك رغم قبول
الطرفين بمقترح الامم المتحده لتهدئه
لساعات وفتح مسارات امنه للحالات
الانسانيه فيما اشار مراسل العربيه الى
عوده تدريجيه للتيار الكهربائي والمياه
لعدد من احياء الخرطوم بالتزامن مع المهله
الطرفين كذلك اكد احتفاضهما بحق الرد على
اي هجوم او تجاوز هذا وكان اعلن كل من
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني على
موافقتهما على مقترح الامم المتحده بفتح
مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه
ومشاهدينا نشير الى هذه الصور المباشره من
الخرطوم لاشتعال نيران وكذلك لدخان كثيف
نشير الى انه منذ ساعات ونحن نرصد وكذلك
متابعه تطورات في الداخل السوداني
التطورات ليس في العاصمه الخرطوم ولكن
كذلك فيما يخص مروي فيما يخص ام درمان
وكذلك كردفان وكانت هناك اشتباكات مستمره
ومتصاعده كان هناك من جهه اخرى اعلان
ومحاوله لتهدئه من الجهه الامميه وكانت
اكدت موافقه الطرفين اي الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني على تهدئه لمده اربع
ساعات لفتح ممرات امنه
لتمكين المدنيين من
محاوله على الاقل الحصول على الاساسيات
اليوميه ولكن رصدنا كذلك من خلال مراقبين
على الارض بان الاشتباكات استمرت في
الساعات الاولى من الاربع ساعات او خلينا
نقول في الدقائق الاولى من الاربع ساعات
من هذه المهله مشاهدينا كانت هناك كذلك
نداءات وكانت هناك محاولات لطرح
دعوات تهدئه اتت من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من مصر من الاتحاد الافريقي ومن
العديد من الدول وكذلك المنظمات التي دعت
الطرفين الى التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار
ستبقى العين على هذه التطورات ستبقى العين
كذلك على تداعياتها فداخل السوداني وهذا
ما سنناقشه بعد قليل كذلك مع ضيوفنا
مشاهدينا تتواصل الاشتباكات في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويقع مقر القياده العامه في المنطقه
الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد نحو 4
كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم كما يتواجد
بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات البحريه
ورئاسه اركان القوات الجويه ويعد مقر
القياده العامه مركزا مهما وحساسا بالنسبه
لقوات الجيش السوداني ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص
في محيط المبنى مع تداول اخبار عن استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله
نرصد اخر هذه التطورات من الخرطوم مع
زميلنا سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه سالم
اهلا بك معنا نقف على اخر التطورات من
عندك سواء فيما يخص مطار الخرطوم ومحيطه
او كذلك فيما فصل اشتباكات التي حدثنا في
نشرات سابقه عن استمرارها بل وعن احتدادها
في بعض المناطق
نعم ما زالت هذه المواجهات تزيد وتيرتها
حين تنقص حين اخر
لكنها ما زالت متواصله حتى هذه اللحظات
لكن في هذه اللحظات هناك هدوء نسبي
في هذه المناطق التي يحتلم حولها قتال في
مطار الخرطوم والقياده العامه للجيش هنا
في الخرطوم وايضا سمع ايضا اطلاق رصاص
كذلك وبعض الاصوات في القصر الجمهوري في
الساعه الماضيه هذه ابرز الاحداث حتى الان
لكن
فقط لنفهم منك هل هذا الهدوء له علاقه
بانتظار الكل كلمه الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان هناك كلمه تؤكد لنا ذلك
بذلك لانه هذه هذا الهدوء ربما هناك هدنه
اعلنت ولكن لم يتم الالتزام بها في
بدايتها بالعكس مع بدايه هذه الهدنه احتدت
احتدت
المناوشات وكذلك احتد الاشتباك كذلك ايضا
في هذه المناطق وسمعت الاصوات قويه جدا في
محيط القياده العامه
وما حولها وكذلك مطار الخرطوم وحتى القصر
الجمهوري كذلك لكن بعد ساعه الافطار في
ساعه الافطار كان هناك ايضا هجوم ايضا في
هذه المناطق بعد الافطار بقليل اي قبل نصف
ساعه من الان او اقل
بدل وضع في اقل حده من قبل تسمع اصوات
قليله جدا في الخرطوم وفي بحر كذلك في
بحري هناك ايضا في منطق كوبر هناك
اشتباكات
احتدت في نهار اليوم وعصر اليوم كذلك كانت
قويه جدا هذه الاشتباك طالما نحن نتحدث عن
اشتباكات هل نحن في اطار الحديث عن حرب
شوارع او هناك استهدافات محدده لبعض
المناطق بعض المؤسسات كيف هي صوره حتى
نفهم بالتفصيل ما الذي يحدث داخل الخرطوم
نعم هي هذه الاشتباكات هي اشبه بحرب
الشوارع وهذا يتضح حينما تجولنا اليوم او
تجولت انا اليوم في الخرطوم وبحري في دوله
هناك ارتكازات للدعم السريع في مناطق
وارتكازات للجيش السوداني في مناطق اخرى
في مناطق يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع مناطق
يسيطر عليها الجيش
وارتكازات لتفتيش حتى
العربات القادمه لهذه الطرق حتى في ساعه
الساعات التي سمحت فيها للهدنه وخروج
الناس بشراء اغراضهم وفتح الممرات الامنه
كذلك
للعالقين سواء في المدارس او في
المستشفيات او في غيرها الممرات الانسانيه
وحتى وصول المساعدات
للمتضررين على المساعدات التي تصل
المستشفيات الادويه حتى الطاقم الطبي الذي
يستطيع ان يصل الى المستشفيات للمساعده في
اسعاف المرضى الذين تم نقلهم اصيبوا في
هذه الاشتباكات
حتى في هذه الهدنه كانت هنالك ايمان
ارتكازات في كل منطقه كما ذكرت التي
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
متفرقه ايضا ارتكازات للدعم السريع
ارتكازات للجيش شوارع يسيطر عليها الجيش
بالكامل شوارع يسيطر على الدعم السريع
بالكامل وهكذا فهذه الامور تجعل انه يعني
حتى الشوارع مقسمه ايضا لهذه القوات
سالم كانت هناك بعض المعلومات تقول بانه
ربما استعملت اسلحه ثقيله الى اي مدى هذه
المعلومات التي طردنا دقيقه
هي دقيقه بالفعل لان الاسلحه ثقيله للغايه
وهذا يعني يفهم من اصواتها نفسه خبير
اسلحه لكن هذه الاسلحه ثقيله جدا ووتيره
هذه يعني حتى
قوه هذه الاسلحه للسمع فقط
يزداد بين الساعه والاخرى يعني فجر امس
كان هذا الصوت مزعج جدا اصوات المضادات
واضحه كذلك اصوات المدفعيه واضحه
استخدام ايضا الارضي
القاذفات كل هذه تم استخدامها في مناطق
متفرقه
والشوايا تتطاير على المباني من حولها
تضررت العديد من المباني منها مثلا بالقرب
من هذه المنطقه مبنى الذي فيه مكاتب
المكاتب العربيه والحدث تضرر هذا المبنى
بشكل كبير تكسره العربات والسيارات من
حوله ايضا مبنى اخر فيه بعض القنوات مثل
قناه الشرق وهو مبنى
العماره الكويتيه وهو مبنى فيه العديد من
القنوات والزملاء من قنوات مختلفه
صحيح صحيح كانت هناك استاد الله يسلم
الجميع اشكرك جزيل الشكر سالم اعود لك
ربما في سياق هذه النشره للوقوف على
تفاصيل اخرى
هذا مشاهدينا وكانت اعلانات اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء في السودان عن
مقتل خمسه مدنيين واصابه 78 في الاشتباكات
الدائره اليوم بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في البلاد وقالت النقابه في بيان
على صفحتها بفيسبوك انه توجد اصابات
ووفيات لم يتم حصرها بسبب عدم تمكن
الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول لبعض المستشفيات
صعوبه التنقل وكذلك بسبب الوضع الامني في
البلاد
وفي اطار الجهود الدوليه لتهدئه اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير الامير
فيصل بن فرحان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا مع رئيس
مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهانه كما اجرى اتصالا اخر مع نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده محمد حمدان واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ضروره التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السودان كما شدد الامير فيصل فرحان
على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق الاطاري
الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن السوداني
وفي السياق اعلن الاتحاد الافريقي ان رئيس
مفوضيته مسافقي محمد سيتوجه فورا الى
السودان للتحدث مع الطرفين بشانه وقف
اطلاق النار وذلك فيما يشهد البلد يوما
ثانيا من الاشتباكات العنيفه وكان عبر
الاتحاد عن قلقه العميق اذا الوضع داعيا
قوه الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الى حمايه
المدنيين وفق ما جاء في بيان صدر عقب
اجتماع طارق لمجلس الامن والسلم التابع
للاتحاد الافريقي
قوات الدعم السريع
انبثقت من قوات الجنجويد في 2003 اعتمد
عليها البشير في هزيمه المتمردين في
دارفور
تاسست في عام 2013
عملت تحت وحده استخبارات حرس الحدود بعدها
تبعت قياده جهاز الامن والمخابرات
في 2016 اصبحت تابعه لرئاسه الجمهوريه وفي
البرلمان يقر تاسيس قوات الدعم السريع تحت
قياده الرئيس رغم تبعيتها للجيش من
اهدافها دعم ومعاونه الجيش والقوات
النظاميه التصدي لحالات الطوارئ المحدده
قانونا تضم نحو 100 الف مقاتل لها مراكز
في دارفور وشمال وغرب كردفان لها وجود
كبير بولايه البحر الاحمر ومواقع قرب
حلايب اسست مقر عديده في العاصمه الخرطوم
مشاهدين ان نتكلم مباشره لمتابعه هذه
الكلمه لاحمد حمدان دقلو نستمع عبد الله
حمدوك بل حمض عبد الله حمدوك نستمع
مشاهدينا سنبقى في متابعه هذه الكلمه او
حينما تبدا ننتقل لها لنستمع لها هذه
الكلمه المنتظره لرئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك وفي هذه الاثناء
نجمل ما اتينا عليه من عواجل كانت او كنا
رصدناها في اخر هذه الساعات كان هناك
تصريح لجوتيرج اذن فيه سقوط قتلى وجرحى من
المدنيين بينهم ثلاث موظفين امميين في
الشبكات السودان وكانت الجهه الامميه
اقترحت تهدئه لاربعه ساعات لتمكين
المدنيين من قضاء حجات احتياجاتهم
الاساسيه وكذلك
لمحاوله وقف الاقتتال لفتره اربعه ساعات
الطرفان سواء الدعم السريع او كذلك الجيش
اعاده الصوت نسمه
احيانا سعيد
بالغائكم
هذا المساء
لكن بنلتقي في ظرف
عصيب وضع يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
انه وضع كارثي
تلتغيقنا اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلتني
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
ان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
رساله ثانيه
كانت
للشعب السوداني
ناشدتهم في الحفاظ على التماسك والوحده
ورساله الثالثه والاخيره
كانت للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي
لمساعده
السودان والوقوف بجانبه في هذه المهنه
حقيقه
تابعتم امس واليوم
ما زالت
هذه الحرب
اللعينه
تقضي على الاخضر واليابس
ايضا
السبب الرئيسي
بعد نداء الامس
الذي جعلني التقى بكم هذا المساء
تتابعون الوضع
الانساني الكارثي في السودان
معاناه الانسان السوداني في هذه الحرب
اصلا
المعاناه كانت موجوده
من اقتصاد
ونهار متدني
نقص في كل الاشياء في الغذاء في الدواء
تفاقم هذا الوضع بشكل اكبر تزل هذه الحرب
هنالك انقطاع مستمر
التيار الكهربائي
المياه الى اخره
لذلك
انا ودت التقيكم اليوم
لاكرر ما قلته بالامس
يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
اليوم قبل غدا
لاتاحه الفرصه
للشعب السوداني بكل مكوناته
ليعود
لمسار الانتقال الذي بدا
من اكثر ما من ثلاثه سنوات
ايضا لن امر تكرار
يظل السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
المتاح للشعب السوداني
لتفادي الانزلاق
للحرب الاهليه
كلنا تابعنا
مالات الحرب الاهليه في مناطق كثيره من
اقليمنا في العالم العربي والافريقي
يجب ان نتفادى ذلك وما زالت الفرصه متاحه
لتفادى هذا الوضع الكارثه
لذلك نطالب
بوقف فوري
اطلاق النار
والوصول لتفهمات تؤدي الى الوقف الدائم
للعادات
في اقل تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام
هدنه تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجاتهم في الدواء
والعلاج
والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى اخره الى
اخره
ايضا
انا اعتقد انه
ما في بديل
لغيرين اننا كسودانيين نقعد
مع بعض في حوار يؤدي
لحل مرضي لكل فئات الشعب السوداني
انا بركز على كلمه حوار
تفاوض مفضي للاتفاق
في تاريخنا القريب في خلال
مش عايزين اكون في متابعه لهذه الكلمه
يبدو بانها مسجله لرئيس الوزراء السابق
عبد الله حمدوك عاد نعود له ونستمع الا
الحوار
انا ايضا
من هذا المنبر
اناشد
وادعو
للرفض اي تدخل اجنبي في الشان السوداني
ولذلك ندعو المجتمع الدولي
يمارس الدور ايجابي لدعم
عوده الحوار السياسي
وايضا اكرر الدعوه
لقياده
الجيش
قياده الدعم السريع
للجلوس فورا في مفاوضات
تؤدي لمعالجه وحلحله الخلافات التي ادت
لهذا الوطن
ايضا
قبل ان اختم هذه المداخله
ادعو الدول
العربيه
والافريقيه والشغيره
لمسانده الشعب السوداني الذي يمر بظروف
انسانيه صعبه جدا
تتطلب تضافر جهود كل المجتمع الدولي في
هذه المهنه
وفي هذا الاطار
سوف ابذل كل الجهد
للمساعده في هذه العمليه
سوف اقوم باجراء اتصالات
بكل العواصف
لتشجيعهم على التحرك على وجه السرعه
لتقديم كل المساعدات الانسانيه الممكنه
للشعب السوداني ومساعدته في هذه المهنه
اختم بعبارات
زعيمنا الافريقي نيلسون مانديلا
عندما قال
سهل جدا
انك
تهدم وتكسر
الابطال هم من يبنون ويصنعون السلام
شكرا جزيلا
معاليك مع هذا الاقتتال برايك هل انتهى
ممكن كان
تلفزيون دبي
اليوم في السودان
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي انتهى وهل هناك
فعليا ايضا مبادره سودانيه سودانيه لحل
الازمه في السودان اليوم
تفضل
ايمان نصار من العين الاخباريه سياده
الرئيس الوزراء
السؤال هل يمكن هل الامور في نظره
التطورات الحاصله منذ الامس حتى اليوم في
السودان هل يمكن ان نقول الامور خرجت عن
السيطره ام ان هناك مساحه للتفاوض واسكات
صوت الرصاص
والمكون المدني لاي مدى يمكن له ان يتدخل
الى جانب طبعا الجهود الاقليميه والدنيا
لمساعده هذه الاطراف المتصارعه لوقف الحرب
شكرا
معرفتك انت بخبرتك الطرفين الان في
السودان ما هي الحلول الثانيه
في متابعه لهذه الكلمه ومؤتمر صحفي مباشر
في الواقع لرئيس الوزراء سابق عبد الله
حمدوك سنبقى مع هذه الصور نعود عندما
يستكمل
حصول له على الاسئله ويبدا في الاجابه
عليها لنفهم كذلك تطورات هذا الموضوع في
كلمته قبل البدء بتلقي الاسئله رئيس وزراء
سابق عبد الله حمدوك تحدث عن ثلاث رسائل
في الواقع قال ارسلت رساله للطرفين
المتنازعين لدعم السريع وكذلك للجيش
السوداني اكدت في هذه الرسائل وجوب وقف
الاقتتال وقال بانه هي حرب المنتصر فيها
خاسر في كل الحالات قال كذلك عبد الله
حمدوك بعثت برساله للشعب السوداني طلبته
بالوحده في هذا الوقت العصيب وبعثت برساله
للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي لمحاوله ايجاد
حلول
لامكانيه تهدئه دائمه تحدث عن الوضع
الانساني الكارثي في السودان وقال بانه
اساسا السوداني يعيش وضعا اقتصاديا متازما
وصعبا وهذه التطورات قد تزيد الوضع
الانساني كارثيه في قادم الايام تحدث عن
السلام قال هو الخيار الوحيد لتفادي
الانزلاق للحرب الاهليه ومشاهدينا نعلم
بان للسودان تجربه مريره مع الحرب الاهليه
وحندوق ذكر بذلك وقال بانه ليس لنا كحل
الا السلام وتبعات هذه الحرب عاشها
السودانيون في كل المناطق
طالب بوقف فوري ودائم لاطلاق النار وقال
بان هناك مساعي لذلك واكد على ان يجب ان
نعمل على خلق هدنه تمكن خاصه السودانيين
من الحصول على حاجيتهم الاساسيه واكد رفضه
لاي تدخل اجنبي من خلال هذه الكلمه تحدث
كذلك رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد الله حمدوك
عن مساعي مختلف الدول الاقليميه والدوليه
وسنذكر مشاهدينا بمختلف هذه العواجل التي
كنا نتابعها مع كلمه رئيس الوزراء السابق
عبد الله حمدوك
حمدو قال ادعو قياده الجيش ودعم السريع
لمفاوضات مباشره
لمعالجه اسباب الازمه هذه عواجل كل
نتابعها اسفل الشاشه منذ قليل تحدث كذلك
حمدوك عن وجوب رفض اي تدخل اجنبي في شان
السوداني وقال بانه لا بديل عن الحوار
المباشر بين السودانيين للوصول لحل يرضي
الجميع سنحاول ان نسال ضيفنا هنا حاضر
معنا في الاستوديو عن كل هذه النقاط
والعين دائما تبقى في الجانب الايمن من
الشاشه هي صور مباشره نلاحظ نيران وهناك
ذلك تصاعد لدخان كثيف وفي الجانب الايسر
لزلنا مع المؤتمر الصحفي لرئيس الوزراء
السابق عبد الله حمدوك سيبدا بالاجابه عن
الاسئله نذهب له ونعود في قراءه لكل
اجوبته
كل
الازمه الحاصل في السودان
وبتتفقوا معي انها في تداخل الاس يعني
فيها
بين الاسئله وكده فانا قلت
دبي الاتفاق الاطار انتهى
هل هنالك مبادره سودانيه للحل لحل الازمه
والنفس السؤال تكرر عده مرات اعتقد
الاتفاق الاطاري
هو جاك جهد
استمر
لشهور طويله
انا لا اعتقد انه انتهى
بقدر ما انه اعتقد
انه
زي ما انا ذكرته في المداخله
تظل امكانيه
العمل المشترك بين السودانيين والحوار
السوداني السوداني
هي البوصله التي تعود
للحلول المستدامه
بهذا المعنى
يظل هو جهد
اكيد
نبني عليه
نشوف شنو ممكن يعني تحسين فيهم
السؤال الثاني من العين الاخباريه
هل خرجت الامور عن السيطره
وقف الحرب ودور المجتمع الدولي
شوف الحرب
دائما قرار
اشعال الحرب
ممكن تمتلك القياده
لكن قرار وقف الحرب
يظل مرتبط
بما يحصل على الارض وفي الميدان ويظل
محكوم بعوامل كثيره جدا
انا ما افتكر
بقدر ما نحن شعرين بانه هنالك ازمه وهنالك
دمار شامل حقيقه في تاريخنا
من بعد الاستقلال الى اليوم ما حصل نحن
واجهنا ازمه بهذا الحجم
نتمنى
انه ما تخرج الامور عن السيطره
وما زالت
امكانيه اننا
يعني نعطي
الحل السلمي فرصه
تظل هذه الامكانيه متاحه وموجوده
بمساعده
الاشقاء
وكل الناس المحبين والاصدقاء السودان
نستطيع ان نحشي الدعم اللازم لنخرج من هذا
النفق
نفتكر
نفس السؤال يعني نفس الكلام عن الامور
خرجت من الصيف
اتصال مع الطرفين
في هذا الاطار
انا تواصلت مع الطرفين
في اليوم قبل اندلاع الحرب
وفي يعني مكالمات طويله
تحدثت معهم
انه
خلونا نقلب خيار
الحوار
والعمل السلمي
الطرفين القدولي انه هم واحد
وانه ده ما خيار بالنسبه له
طبعا
كلنا شاهدنا اندلعت الحرب الى اخره فبيبقى
الاتصال ما قبل الحرب ما عنده ما عنده
معنى
الحرب بدات امس
اكيد تكون من الناس مغدرين جدا انه
في صعوبه كبيره جدا في التواصل مع
القيادات اللي في الميدان كده لكن
يعني حابزل كل الجهد بانه اتواصل مع الناس
اللي حولهم معاهم هم متى ما اتيحت الفرصه
سوف لن اعلوا جهدا في ذلك
الخطوات العمليه الخروج من هذا الصراع
طريق مسدود
استل انا انا يعني متفائل
تخيل انه
مهما نشوف من من يعني انسداد افق
وظلاميه الى اخره
تظل باستمرار هنالك امكانيه للجلوس
ومعالجه هذه المساله
يعني نحن شفنا في تجارب كل الشعوب في
الدنيا
ماذا لن نمشي في نفس الطريق اللي حصلت فيه
يعني ماسي ودمار حصلت في اوروبا حصلت في
مناطق كثيره في العالم العربي في افريقيا
في اسيا الى اخره
اعتقد اي كلام عن انه نحن وصلنا لطريق
مسدود ما صحيح
تظل امكانيه اننا نقدر نعالج هذه المساله
يتم
بمشاركه الاصدقاء والاشقاء
وبقياده الداخل السوداني نساعد هذه
العمليه
في اوقف المساعدات وما هي يعني الرساله
المجتمع الدولي
ه يعني
وامر مؤسف جدا
ترحم عليه
ثلاثه اشخاص الذين فقدوا ارواحهم من الدعم
السريع واكيد الحرب هي ما بتفرز يعني
الوطني ولا الاجنبي الى اخره
ودعم الدميه اوقف المساعدات
نتيجه للتعرض افراد منهم
يعني ما تعرضوا له نحن نغدر ذلك لكن نتمنى
انه تتحسن الظروف مشبب في كل القوى الخيره
اللي ممكن تساعد شعبنا لانه في امكانيه
بتاعت انها تعمل معنا وترجع عشان تمارس
دوره وانا في في في نهايه المداخله
وده اصلا هذا المؤتمر الصحفي احنا قصدنا
به وانه نناشي الاشقاء وخاصه في الدول
العربيه
ليد مدى لمد يد العون للشعب السوداني في
محنته هذه لذلك نتمنى من المجتمع الدولي
انه هذه
المعاسي
تسمح بانهم يتوقفوا تماما عن مدين العون
دور القوى المدنيه مهدد بالانتهاء في
الوضع الراهن
لا اعتقد ذلك
الدور المجتمع المدني في كل قوه الحيه
اتحادات نقابات احزاب سياسيه الى اخره
راسخ
وعنده جذور عميقه جدا في تربه السودان
هنا يعني مؤسساتنا في القطاع المدني
يعني عمرها اكثر من خمسين ستين سبعين سنه
تدربت ونشات على النضال ضد المستعمر
واستمرت في كل العهود ناضلت
يعني يمكن اتقنت فن العمل في كل الابصم
داونز اللي بيتعرض لها الشعب السوداني
لذلك انا ما عندي خوف انه
المجتمع المدني دوره حيتهدد او ينتهي هذه
يعني ممكن نسميها جفت او تراجع
بسيط
احنا بنسميها بالدارج السوداني للعتره
اللي بتصلح المشي
فاكيد سوف ينفتح الطريق واسع من جديد
ليصير فيه الانسان الحر يبني مجتمع افضل
استعين العبارات
اللندي في 73 عندما هدم عليه
المقر الرئاسه الى اخره ما افتكر في خوف
على المجتمع المدني لانه
ودور وراسك وعميق
بيظل موجود
في اخر سؤال عن مبادره مصريه سعوديه
انا حقيقه شفته
لكن ما اعتقد
في حاجه كونكري في المبادره ممكن نسميها
السعوديه مصريه او مصريه سعوديه اتمنى ذلك
اتمنى انه الاقليم
[موسيقى]
في ساهم
معنا في حل هذه المساله وانا افتكر في
امكانيه للمساله دي وخاصه يعني نحن بنشهد
في هذا المجال
انفتحت امكانيات كبيره جدا في حلحله قضايا
ما كنا بنعتقد انها ممكن تحل في هذا الزمن
يعني
حاصل بين السعوديه وايران
المجهود الكبير جدا بقياده الامارات
السعوديه في حال حاله القضايا
استمرت لفتره في اليمن
رجوع سوريا للمحيط العربي دي كلها يعني
لمسه هوب نتمنى انه السودان ما يكون هو
النشاز
اذا كان هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لرئيس وزراء
السابق عبد الله حمدوك في البدايه كانت
هناك كلمه له سنعود الى تفاصيلها لاحقا
ولكن بعد ذلك اجاب على مجموعه من الاسئله
كذلك اجاباته ستكون محل تساؤل بعد قليل
لضيوفنا في هذه الساعه ولكن قبل كل هذا
سنتابع معكم هذه اللقطات التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل مشاهدينا لقوات الدعم السريع تقول
فيها انها اسقطت مروحيه عسكريه في بحر
وهذه هي الصور التي اتتنا منذ قليل الدعم
السريع يقول من خلال هذه الصور التي
ينشرها بانه اسقط مروحيه في الخرطوم بحري
مشاهدينا نبقى مع هذه الصور ولكن نذكر
كذلك بكلمه كنا استمعنا لها منذ قليل
لرئيس الوزراء السابق عبد الله حمدوك تحدث
فيها عن نقاط عده في الواقع تحدث عن
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه ودعا الى
محاوله طرح
مبادره لتحقيق هدنه دائمه وقال بان الحرب
سيخرج منها الكل خاسر حتى المنتصر فيها
خاسر وهذه لقطات كذلك وصلتنا مشاهدينا منذ
قليل من اندرمان الدعم السريع يقول فيها
انه سيطر على مقر سلاح المهندسين في ام
درمان وكانت قوه الدعم السريع قد اعلنت
سيطرتها امس على المقر ولكن الجيش قد نفى
ذلك وكانت هناك اكثر من اخبار اكدها الطرف
الاول نفاها فيما بعد الطرف الثاني
وبالتالي نحاول في كل مره ان نقف على اخر
التطورات وكذلك نستند على الصور
والفيديوهات التي تردنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تليفون
تبقى العين على كل هذه التطورات على كل
هذه التفاصيل والفيديوهات كذلك سنبقى في
متابعه كل هذه التفاصيل ولكن سنعود لكلمه
ريس وزراء السابق عبد الله حمدوك اتى على
نقاط عده في الواقع تفاصيل سنحاول ان نسال
فيها ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو اسامه
المصطفى الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
سيد اسامه اهلا بك معنا سنحاول ان ناتي
على كل النقاط هي كثيره في الواقع ولكن
خليني ابدا او اسمح لي ان ابدا بالملفت
الملفت في كلام عبد الله حمدوك حديث عن
اتصال هاتفي اجراه مع قيادات الطرفين سواء
الدعم السريع او الجيش السوداني كنت حضرتك
في متابعه لهذه الكلمه معنا هنا في
الاستوديو قال بانه لما اتصلت بهم الطرفين
اكد بانه الخيار العسكري غير مطروح ولكن
بعد ذلك بساعات بدات وانطلقت الاشتباكات
هل نفهم بانه كان هناك انفلات امني صار
فوتر الموضوع او ان ساعه الصفر محسوبه من
الاول من احد هذه الاطراف
الواقع ربما الوقت غير مناسب للانتقاد في
الظرف الذي نحن فيه دلوقتي لكن انتقد لا
انا اتحدث عن نفسك
الدكتور حمدوك بشكل او باخر وكل التيارات
السياسيه سوى كان الحريه والتغيير او
المجلس المركزي او الكتله الديمقراطيه او
حتى الاحزاب السياسيه بشكل او باخر هم
السبب فيما يحدث الان في السودان انت تحمل
عبد الله حمدوك ما الت اليه الاوضاع واحد
هو واحد من الذين نعمل لانه بعد قبل 25
اكتوبر
في 23 اكتوبر او 24 اكتوبر تقع فيهم جورج
فليمن المبعوثه الامريكي
القرن الافريقي وكان الحديث في واضح جدا
في انه غير
الكتله السياسيه الموجوده خلال الاسبوع
القادم يعني ولكن ينجح في انه يفعل ذلك
وكان هنالك ضوء اصفر للبرهان وقلب السلطه
واستولى على السلطه بالطريق العسكريه قلت
منذ قليل بانه لا استثني اي طرف داخل
السوداني بتحميله مسؤوليه ما يحدث طيب
ولكن قلت كذلك شيء جميل فيما بعد قلت بانه
تحميل المسؤوليه في هذا الوقت والسودان
يعيش ظروف صعبه مبكر طب خلينا نحاول نفهم
كيف بدات القصه على الاقل نحاول ان نفهم
من الذي اطلق اول رصاصه ودفع بهذه
الاشتباكات لانه عبد الله حمدوك مع حفظ
الالقاب في كلمته قال بانه بحسب روايته هو
طبعا التي نقلها قال بانه الاطراف لم تكن
تدعم فرضيه الحرب او طرح الحرب تعتقد بانه
هذا الشكل الذي نتابعه من الاشتباكات كان
محضر احد الطرفين كان له خيار الحرب او
كان يبرمج لهذه الخطوه كان هنالك احتقان
شديد بين الطرفين خلال الشهرين الماضيين
او ايضا قبل
بعد 25 اكتوبر بعد
السلاح السلطه العسكريه على الحاله
المدنيه دائما كان هنالك خلافات
يعني
اجتماعات فيها كثير من
الاحتقان
لكن منها لليوم من هذا التاريخ لليوم كانت
هناك تطورات تقاربت جهات مدنيه كذلك تقاثر
او خلينا نقول صارت انقسامات داخل الحريه
بعض من القوى الحريه والتغيير وقعت
الاتفاق الاطار وبعض الاخر رفض يوقع صحيح
وبدا
النبره الصوت ما بين الطرفين تعلى بالانت
امينه البرهان في وسط القوات العسكريه في
كثير من الاجتماعاته يمكن الاسبوع الاخير
ظهر في اكثر من مكان نرفع فيه نبره احتواء
الجيش للموقع للموقف كله فيما
حماتي او الرئيس محمد حمدان دوبلو في
كقايه قوات الدعم السريع ايضا في منابره
الخاصه ايضا رفع نبره صوت عالي في التحدي
مع صحيح وكانت هناك تصريحات
من الطرفين ونحن على فكره ناقشنا هذه
المواضيع وهذه التصريحات في نشراتنا وفي
برامجنا على قناه العربيه ولكن كان دائما
صوت السوداني يؤكد على انها خلافات داخليه
داخل مؤسسه الكبيره للجيش بما انه كانت
هناك نوايا لدمج دعم العسكري وبان هذا
الموضوع محلول داخل القيادات ما الذي حدث
حتى الوضع انا في اعتقادي الحدث انه هنالك
من يتحين فرصه اي زريعه
للوصول للوضع نحن فيه حتى ينسحب البساط من
ارجل الحركه السياسيه
والاتفاق الاداري اي متفق عليه
حتى الان بشكل او باخر ولكن من لا ادري
ولكن احدهما كان له هذا الدور
لسبب واحد للانانيه والماكيه
والمحاوله الاستئثار بالسلطه باي شكل من
الاشكال من الطرفين انا لا استثني
لا برهان ولا حتى محمد حمدان
بالنسبه للسلطه استاذ اسامه يقول بعض لا
زال الوقت مبكر الحديث عن تقاسم السلطه
نحن في مرحله تقاسم الرتب داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه هل هذا هو اصل الموضوع هو في
اعتقادي الخاصيه طبعا في اطار قراءات حتى
الان لانه لا شيء ثابت في اعتقادي انه
ليست
الوصول الى السلطه بينما الاستمرار في
السلطه هذا هو يمكن قد يكون هو الهدف اللي
تفجر بهذا الوضع هنالك محاوله من احد
الاطراف حمايه نفسه خوفا من ان يتم
الانقلاب عليه
البرهان البرهان او حمايه خايفه من ان يتم
الاعتداء عليه بشكله باخر لانه نبره الصوت
خلال اخر اربعه ايام كان واضح جدا من
الطرفين
سيتم انفجار
رصاصه واحده انطلقتها كان يفجر الوضع اللي
احنا فيه والدليل على كده ما حدث في منطقه
مروي عندما
ذهبت قوات الدعم السرايا الى منطقه ورك
نمراوي بحجه انشاء قائده عسكريه موازيه
للقائد العسكريه الموجوده في المنطقه لا
يعقل هذا الشيء بالتحديد ولكن بانه
بالاتفاق لانه طرحنا هذه النقطه في نشرات
سابقه وقيل بانه الجيش السوداني يعلم بهذه
الخطوه وكان هناك اتفاق بين الطرفين حضرتك
تؤكد بانه او على الاقل تقرا بان هذا غير
منطقي هذا الجيش السوداني في في مرحله
اخرى نفى انه هم كان في اتفاق ولكن ضمنيا
بما انه قوات هي جزء من
يعني من الجيش السوداني بموجب القانون
بند رقم خمسه من قانون الدعم السريع فما
في مفر الا يكون هذا الامر بتفويض ضمني
القوات التي تحركت مفوضه ضمنيا ولكن هل تم
اعلام او يعني
اخذ
من رئيس مجلس السياده القائد العام
العسكري هذا هو المبهم في
التصعيد بين الطرفين استاذ اسامه نحن
نتابعه ونشاهده منذ فتره ليست بالقصيره في
الواقع والكل كما استشرفت حضرتك وقرات
حضرتك قلت بانه كان شيء متوقع كانت هناك
كان هناك انفلات متوقع ولكن متى هذا لا
احد يعرفه طيب ولكن هناك اطراف كذلك في
الدخله السوداني اطرف مدنيه وهناك اطراف
اقليميه مهتمه بالتطورات احد اهم هذه
المنظمات هي الاتحاد الافريقي
الم ينتبه احد او ان هذه الاطراف باتت غير
قادره على محاوله على الاقل طرح تقارب بين
الطرفين طيله الاشهر السابقه الواقع نعم
فشلت كل هذه القوه القوى الاطراف يعني
الرباعيه لم تستطع ان تصل وتخلك بيئه من
التوافق ما بين المدنيين والعسكريين
الاتحاد الافريقي بما فيها ممثلها دائما
موجود في السودان موسى فيكي لم يستطيع ان
يسحب البساط من الازمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كلهم عجزوا من
ان يوفقوا ما بين كل الاطراف لانه المساله
هنالك في الطياره السياسي السوداني موجود
ازمه حقيقيه تسمى ازمه الانانيه كلهم
يمارسون الانانيه بدرجه عاليه جدا سواء
كان التيار السياسي
والتغيير بشقيها والاحزاب السياسيه اللي
هي متشرمه اصلا فيما داخلها اذا المساله
ليست سهله الانفجار الحدث هو كان نتيجه
طبيعيه لكل الخلل الحاصل في هذا في الساحه
السياسيه والمشهد السياسي ساعود لك استاذ
اسامه للحديث عن نقاط اخرى ولكن مشاهدينا
نذكر ببعض الملفات ذات الصله حيث طالبت
جامعه دول العربيه
المتحاربين في السودان بوقف النار فورا
حقنا لدماء المدنيين ومقدرات الشعب
السوداني ووحده اراضيه وسيادته كما حس
بيان الاجتماع الذي دعت اليه كل من
السعوديه ومصر طرفي النزاع الى العوده
السريعه الى المسار السلمي لحل الازمه
السودانيه وحضرت جامعه الدول العربيه من
خطوره تداعيات التصعيد في السودان على
المستويين الداخلي والاقليمي واكد البيان
على استعداد جامعه الدول العربيه بذل كافه
المساعي من اجل معاونه ومس اعده السودان
على انهاء الازمه الراهنه بما يتوافق مع
مصالح السودانيين واعربت جامعه الدول
العربيه عن اسفها الشديد لسقوط ضحايا خلال
الاشتباكات الاخيره في السودان
هذا وكانت عرضت مصر وجنوب السودان الوساطه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بعد المواجهات التي بدات بينهما امس السبت
في العاصمه الخرطوم ومن دون اخرى ووفقا
لبيان لرئاسه المصريه فقد ناشدت جاره
السودان الاطراف السودانيه تغلب صوت
الحكمه والحوار السلمي وذلك خلال التصلن
هاتفي بين رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
ورئيس جنوب السودان سيلفاكير في موضوع ذات
صله اخر كان اذان كذلك رئيس البعثه
الامميه في السودان فولك الهجوم على
موظفيها الامم المتحده والوصول والمباني
التابعه لمنظمات الاغاثه في دارفور واشار
المبعوث الاممي ايضا الى مقتل ثلاثه
موظفين من برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في
اشتباكات اندلعات في كبير بشمال دارفور
السبت اثناء ادائهم لواجباتهم ونقل بيان
للبعثه عن بيرت شعوره بالانزعاج الشديد من
التقارير التي تفيد بان مقذوفات اصابت
منشات الامم المتحده ومبان انسانيه اخرى
بالاضافه الى تقارير عن نهب مباني الامم
المتحده وغيرها من المباني الانسانيه في
عده مواقع في دارفور
مشاهدينا نتابع دائما هذه الصور وهذه
اللقطات التي وصلتنا منذ قليل لعناصر من
الجيش ينشرون صورا لدخولهم لقاعده مرويه
الجويه شمال الخرطوم هذه المنطقه جدا مهمه
على المستوى الاستراتيجي هذه المنطقه هي
مهبط لطائرات وكذلك مطار مروي جدا مهم
يسمى بالميناء الجوي الذي يربط بين دول
خليجيه اوروبيه افريقيه وهو كذلك نافذه
سياحيه مهمه جدا مشاهدينا
للسودان وسمي لكي تهبط فيه طائرات ضخمه
على كل سنبقى مع هذا الفيديو
وقبل ان نستكمل كذلك هنا من الاستوديو
نقاشنا مع ضيفنا نذهب لنستطلع على اوضاع
في او من مدينه مروي مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا كنت افتنا في
نشرات سابقه ببعض الاخبار التي تخص ليس
فقط المدينه بل مطار مروي وما حدث فيه هل
توضحت صوره اكثر من عندك
نعم الصوره حسب المصادر الرسميه في الجيش
وحسب القيادات بعض القيادات اكدت للعربيه
بان القوات المسلحه السودانيه بسطت
سيطرتها بالكامل على القاعده العمليه هي
قاعده مروي الجويه
وبسطت ايضا السيطره على مطار مروي الدولي
وان الاشتباكات توقفت الان بحكم ان قوات
الدعم السريعه الان باتت خارج هذه القاعده
هذه المعلومات كنا قد اشرنا اليها
كمعلومات اوليه خلال الساعات الماضيه ولكن
تم التاكيد وتم التامين عليها بعد ان
ذكرنا من المصادر العسكريه كنت كذلك
وصيتنا ببعض المعلومات المتعلقه بمعتقلين
او على الاقل موقوفين خلينا نقول تم اخذهم
الى المستشفى
نشرنا هذه المعلومات بكل حذر حتى التاكد
من دقتها هل توضحت صوره فيما يخص هذه
المعلومه كذلك هل هناك اعداد هل هناك
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هم الان يتلقون
العلاج بمستشفيات الولايه هنا في الولايه
الشماليه
توفيق الاوضاع الان يجري على قدم الوثائق
من قبل القياده العسكريه هنا في المنطقه
ربما يسمح للاعلام بالوصول الى مطار مروي
او القاعده خلال الساعات المقبله او صباح
الغد لمعرفه الاوضاع على طبيعتها من عين
المكان واستجلاء الحقيقه كامله اود شكرا
جزيل الشكر زميله مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي من مدينه مروي نعود لك في نشرتنا
القادمه نزار للوقوف على كل هذه التطورات
اكمل بما تبقى من هذا الوقت من هذه الساعه
معك استاذ اسامه استاذ اسامه كنا نتحدث عن
الوصفات وكنا نتحدث عن المبادرات خاصه
الاقليميه
والدوليه لمحاوله فرض واقع للتهدئه هل
تعتقد هذا ممكن في الساعات القادمه او
نحن نعلم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عمل الاتصال مع وزير خارجيه السعودي
بتحرك هذا التحرك قد يكون هو السبب بشكل
او باخر في الهدنه اليوم
ان ياتي من داخل السودان في المقام الاول
في المقام الاول ثم اقليميا ثم اتحاد
الافريقي ثم المجتمع الدولي المجموعه
الرباعيه اذا تحركوا
باستراتيجيه واضحه للرفع الصدع بين
الطرفين ممكن تحصل نتيجه ايجابيه باسرع ما
يقول لانه الطرفين قد تكون الشرار التي
فجرت هذه
الشبكات لم يكونوا مستعدين لها لكن على
ذكر الاشتباكات باختصار لو سمحت نحن منذ
بدانا تغطيه هذه التطورات كنا نتحدث دائما
عن اشتباكات في قناه العربيه منذ قليل عبد
الله حمدوك يتحدث عن حرب واعادها اكثر من
مره كما تابعت معنا هل نحن في اطار حرب
حقيقيه اذا لم يتم ضبط النفس بشكل كويس مع
قوات العسكريه الموجوده
القوات الحركات المسلحه الموجوده داخل
العاصمه وهي قوات ليست قليله كبيره جدا قد
ندخل الى خاصه بين قوسين نحن الان
الحرب او
الاشتباكات ما بين قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه ولكن اذا تطور
الامر الى حاله جهويه واحنا نعرف انه
الحاله الجهويه معناه حركه من ناوي غرب
حركه
مالك عقار غرب حركه الدكتور جبريل غرب
والسيد فنحن سنكون سيد اسامه امام حرب
اهليه حقيقيه قد نصل لهذه
ولكن ضبط النفس والحكمه والتعامل وفق
معطيات الواقع المعزز يستطيع ان نطلع
انتهى او تفكرك جزيل الشكر على كل ما
تفضلت به السيد اسامه المصطفى الكاتب
المحلله السياسي السوداني هناك معنى في
الاستوديو شكرا
مشاهدينا بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الساعه ولكن تغطيه العربيه مستمره
للتطورات في داخل السوداني بعد قليل
الزميله ليال الاختيار تلقاكم لمتابعه
التفاصيل التطورات ساعه بساعه من داخل
السودان ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات